yes fellow maniacs I'm going to talk
about the Avengers trailer how can I not
talk about the New Avengers trailer that
will be weird what do we do we get ready
so as many of you know I'm a huge Joss
Whedon fan I love his work I think he's
one of the feed directors who can take a
plethora of different kinds of
characters and put them all in one movie
and make them all relevant and it looks
like he's gonna do just that I'm excited
as hell how can you not get excited for
this movie once you see this trailer I
mean this could be the shortest video
I've ever done I could just be like yeah
all right and I'm not gonna do that
we're gonna talk about it so not only is
it cool because this is the Avengers
trailer but you see loki and loki looks
badass dude he looks dark it'll be every
man for himself yeah he's gone from the
god of mischief to the god of blowing up
streets if that does not show that
you've moved up in life I don't know
what does and after that you've got your
31 flavors of superheroes or you know a
few less but you know you see Hawkeye
Black Widow Captain America Thor Iron
Man even The Incredible Hulk
played by Mark Ruffalo and everyone's
like dude this is gonna suck Mark
Ruffalo suck I've never been the biggest
Mark Ruffalo fan I wish Edward Norton
was in the movie god forbid Mark Ruffalo
sucks you have a plethora of other
heroes know you have an assembly of
Avengers to pick from even got Agent
Coulson
everyone knows Agent Coulson is an
actual badass you know just pick your
poison
there was just a teaser trailer you
don't know much about the plot other
than yeah it has Avengers and you know
streets blow up and that's always bad
now what I really liked is from what you
can see in the trailer the characters
haven't changed I was worried that
Robert Downey jr. wouldn't feel like you
know the Tony Stark that we've all grown
to love I don't know why I was just as a
paranoia of mine but he has the best
lines in the trailer which I'm not gonna
room for you check out the trailer
you'll thank me and I see some people
comment like what the frost giants
aren't injuries series it's a teaser
trailer dude it's not gonna show you
anything last teaser trailer for a
summer movie we've got Jim Gordon was
just laying in a bed gun version he
showed more than that and just saying
I'm glad I'm excited for this I'm glad
this trailer was good I'm glad the movie
looks good blood look he looks like a
badass even though his hairs like long
and nasty he looks like a Lionel Luthor
season 3 because we could have just as
easily seen this trailer but like it was
okay but this looks badass I was really
pleased with how last summer when the
summer of 2012 might slay all others and
if for nothing else Scarlett Johansson
still hot
even in slow-mo has been sexy Scarlett
Johanson voice and if you're not
impressed by now the last line of the
trailer if we can't protect the earth
damn sure we'll avenge it oh yeah are
you not excited by now
arias way this movie's gonna be awesome
so as far as teaser trailers go you know
that first trailer that comes out months
before the movie that doesn't show much
this is one of the cooler ones so have
you seen the Avengers trailer what did
you think of it comment below let me
know we're gonna talk about this yeah
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]